and
we're just waiting one moment to get
started but if anyone needs anything
there are folks in green shirts Granite
State ambassadors that can assist if you
need restroom or something they are
strategically around the room so
Secretary of State you're actually over
here sir
so
I'm not going to high
the Speaker of the House
is used to this
.
foreign
good morning
[Music]
Welcome to the New Hampshire house
chamber
to get started right now I'd like to
introduce some of our special guests
[Applause]
chief justice Gordon McDonald
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
it is a tradition that whenever the
governor comes in we we automatically
stand and when I hit the uh
Hammer then everybody sits
I'd like to introduce Martha Manson The
New Hampshire Civics executive director
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you so much thank you to speaker
Packard for welcoming us here today
allowing us to use this incredible space
um my name is Martha Madsen and I direct
New Hampshire Civics a nonpartisan
non-profit dedicated to teaching civics
to those in every zip code every
perspective
our programs help students understand
how our government works
how to find the facts and how to be good
and active citizens
people of all political opinions agree
that civic education is the best way to
unite our country
we believe that all New Hampshire
students deserve high quality
information
Hands-On learning that lasts
and a confidence that their voice
matters
speaking of voices I am thrilled to
introduce
Charlotte cotty
[Applause]
I'm pleased to introduce the family of
Hayden Simmons Erica Lemire and Jennifer
Simmons
New Hampshire kid governor elect Hayden
summits
next it is my privilege to introduce to
you our new New Hampshire kid executive
Council
um so if when I introduce you please
Sierra
Bollinger
she's from Namaste Montessori School in
Goffstown
Kaylee cook of beader beaver Meadow in
Concord
Emily parent of Edward Fenn Elementary
all the way up in Gorham
Ava straight hand
and over
Jordan seguya of Bicentennial Elementary
and Andrew Swanson of North Salem
I would also like to recognize and thank
so many people so you're going to have
to forgive me I have a lot of people to
thank for this pulling this off
um primarily house speakers Sherman
Packard
chief justice Gordon McDonald
executive counselor Janet Stevens and
Secretary of State Dave Scanlon and of
course his Excellency Governor
[Music]
and I'd like to thank the other
officials who are here today your
presence is much appreciated and really
makes this event very meaningful so
thank you for the for all the officials
foreign
and obviously I want to thank again
councilor Stevens chief justice McDonald
and Governor soon for joining us today
and thank you all for making time to
attend the New Hampshire kid Governor
inauguration
Welcome to the New Hampshire House of
Representatives
[Music]
it has been my honor to serve as Speaker
of the House and a privilege
to serve as a New Hampshire state
representative for going on 33 years
in this 204 year old legislative chamber
in America
the house chamber has held Governors
inaugurations since 1819.
and is pleased to host the New
Hampshire's fifth kid Governor
inauguration
and as his proper protocol
each time that the legislature gathers
in this chamber we pledge allegiance to
the flag
if everyone can please stand I will now
ask our kid Governor executive
counselors to come forward and lead us
the United States
to the Republic for which it stands and
nation under God indivisible with
[Music]
okay well I'll try to be brief because
the real stars today are the young
people who have won
this real election that we held and this
is the fifth time now
that we have held this inauguration one
one year we were over at the Supreme
Court because we were facing
coven but we've had it now this is the
fifth time we've done this so it's
really exciting
for me and for I think for many of us
um and although we can't include the 2
can't all be in one room today we're
confident we're reaching them still
through a live stream
thanks to all of you who are watching
from your homes or from your classrooms
and later there will be a video that
will be recorded and shared
um through YouTube in a few days
many many thanks to Virginia Drew and
the general court staff for their
um okay the New Hampshire kid Governor
program exemplifies the best of civil
collaboration and Civic engagement
because we have worked alongside the
national kid Governor office Brian Co
Francesco was with us today from the
national kid Governor office and we're
honored to have him with us today for
the first time
um
of course my organization New Hampshire
Civics the New Hampshire Institute of
politics at St Anselm The Visitor Center
here at the State House
staff officials from all three branches
of government
teachers parents and students so you can
see what incredible collaboration this
was and what a team effort we are now
able to gather here today for this
remarkable ceremony
celebrating the important voices of
young people in New Hampshire and it has
been our privilege to see this program
develop and grow over the past five
years
we have lived through some remarkable
times
and it still remains of utmost
importance that we remain steadfast in
teaching government citizenship and the
rule of law
to promote opportunities for youth to
practice their civic skills
this ceremony today is just one step in
a year-long curriculum available free of
cost to all New Hampshire's fifth grade
classrooms
last fall over 2 000 students from all
10 counties took part in the New
Hampshire kid Governor program
this real life experience reviews the
three branches of government that should
be taught in fourth grade
and how they interact as identified in
um
this program examines the qualities of
leadership requires engagement in
research and media literacy
and offers practice in campaigning and
elections in short it teaches knowledge
skills and attitudes it takes to be a
positive and participating citizen
I thank our partner the New Hampshire
Institute of politics for believing in
this idea years ago five years ago now
and taking a chance on it with me
thanks to Ann common
and Neil Levesque for their amazing
partnership
and to Saint Anselm interns I hope
they're watching remotely Kayla
panagrosso and Julia Matt
many thanks to the general court for
allowing the ceremony to take place here
in the house chamber
and to Virginia drew the director of The
Visitor Center without who could not do
this without her
and all of the public officials who've
okay
okay we thank the New Hampshire kid
Governor Advisory Board and our
financial sponsors Fidelity Investments
I don't know if Joe Murray is here today
the New Hampshire Nea
Megan Tuttle no Delta Dental and the
Nashua teachers union we also thank
raponi Automotive for helping us with
deliveries to schools all around the
state
I would like to thank the New Hampshire
Civic staff Heather McNeill and
Claudette canarium for all their help on
this project
especially with two different
postponements
we had a lot of reshuffling to do a
couple of different times
of course we could not do this without
the dedication of teachers
and the support of Administrators and
the passionate engagement of students so
thank you all for making this happen
and I'd just like to give a special
thank you to Lorraine genesto do you
mind standing for just a minute Luanne
[Applause]
um
she has
she has grown this program from just an
idea into a large impactful program that
is Statewide
her heart is full of compassion
okay so now we get to the fun stuff
Charlotte cotty I would like to ask you
to come up and deliver your farewell
address
foreign
thank you Martha thank you Speaker of
House chairman Packard and Senator
Sharon Carson for your warm welcome
I'm Charlotte cotty the previous kid
governor of New Hampshire and I think my
term was a very important and memorable
experience of my life it was such a
unique opportunity and I met many
amazing people along the way
congratulations Hayden for your startup
term it's going to be an exciting
Adventure
during my term I learned three things
one is that it's helpful to reflect
after an event or even just a
conversation I'd reflect on what I
learned I learned a lot second is that
it's okay to be nervous
nerves made the experience electric and
third our words can influence people and
greatly affect people and touch their
hearts I learned the influence words
after my teacher of the year speech at
the Bridge's house I was told I touched
many hearts that day
during my term I learned oh as kid
Governor my platform was homelessness
and it's just like and it's still a
significant issue I felt terrible for
people who were living in such harsh
conditions and with no place to call
home with the help of Luanne
my term was spent organizing ideas that
would help these suffering people
throughout my term I got to implement so
many things that I'm proud of I was the
host on the game show Granite State
Challenge I visited the friendly Kitchen
in Concord I held a sock drive with my
executive counselor Tainan as part of
his platform I even spoke at the
superintendent's breakfast and the 40th
Somersworth International Children's
Festival
my favorite event was the friendly
kitchen a soup kitchen in Concord that
helps the food insecure it was a very
unique experience that was worth sharing
with the world so I made a video about
it
I took a tour of the kitchen and I ate a
spectacular meal I think this event was
important because it showed me that
there are more people trying to help
people in this world
I think the kid Governor program has
inspired me through Civic and social
experiences and offered me an
opportunities to serve my community
it has provided me more experiences in
the power of my words I've even written
and delivered many great spirits many
many great speeches with the mentorship
of Luanne
every day I'm learning how to be a more
powerful writer and use my own voice I
haven't determined what I want what I
want to be when I grow up but I will
never stop going out of my way to serve
my community and make my voice be heard
I'd like to thank Luan geneste for
helping me so much throughout my term
and arranging my events I'd also like to
thank Martha Madsen
um the director of New Hampshire Civics
governor sununu and first lady Valerie
sununu my previous fifth grade teacher
Miss robichaux and my mom she has been
my encouragement and helping him
throughout my whole term and I couldn't
have done anything without her by my
side
thank you everyone and good luck Hayden
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you Charlotte
for the speech
but more importantly for all the work
that you did over this past year to
advocate for solutions to homelessness
in New Hampshire
we know your voice and your message have
been heard throughout the state
and we know that your future is bright
[Applause]
I'd now like to introduce to you Neil
Levick
who is the director of the New Hampshire
Institute of politics at St Anselm
College
[Applause]
by the way Mrs jeunesse was my teacher
in the fifth grade so when she came to
us with this idea I said well I got to
say yes my fifth Goodyear teacher so I
just wanted to point out a couple things
so about a few weeks ago governor sununu
spoke from here on his inaugural address
and he talked about first and foremost a
very important aspect of civic education
and how much it's important that we
understand everything that's going on
outside of our house everything that's
going on in the State House everything
that's going on nationally in politics
and having an understanding of our
democracy and how important it was and
for years you know we've had some really
smart people try to put together a
program to try to see how we could get
civic education for not just young
people but all people in country
and the mistake we made was that we
didn't go to all of you the fifth
graders because the fifth graders of
course had the answer
they knew what they wanted to
participate in
and this kid Governor program is exactly
the type of thing it's because of you
guys this is so successful
we're now in our fifth year the speaker
mentioned eighteen hundred students 1800
people just like you in New Hampshire
all throughout the state are involved
what we really need to do is to take
this program
to every student in the country
so that's for your to-do list for the
next year you can add that
so this is a great program we're happy
to be partners I just like to point out
that all um
Luanne and Martha and Ann Camen are
really put a lot of effort into this
program it's we're very thankful to be
great Partners but I want to also
mention the fact that someone's not here
is that our first lady Valerie sununu
five years ago and we said hey Valerie
first lady would you be willing to come
we've got this idea we're doing this
thing and she said Count Me In
and so she's really made a difference
for the 1800 plus students that have
been involved just this year in the five
years since and so we'd be remiss if we
didn't thank her for what she did so
congratulations we're gonna have a great
year and thank you all for coming and
all right I'm not done I'm sorry so
we have a new secretary of state in New
Hampshire and he administers many
different things but especially our
elections so I'd like to introduce you
to Mr David scanler the Secretary of
thank you Neil
thank you Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker Governor sununu chief justice
McDonald councilor Stevens
alkaline kid Governor Charlotte Cody
and incoming Governor Hayden Simmons
and everyone else who's in attendance
today
it is a privilege for me to certify the
results
of the kid governor election held in
2022 on November 15th
we the underside hereby confirm the
results certified on the November 15
2020-22 election
for the Statewide election for the
office of New Hampshire kid governor
we proclaim the Victor as Hayden Simmons
in the town of Plaistow New Hampshire
in testimony whereby I here unto set my
hand and affixed the great steel of the
State of New Hampshire at the State
House and the City of Concord on this
20th day
actually it's now in February February
6th I think this was supposed to happen
a week ago
in the year 2023
signed by David Scanlon Secretary of
State and Luan geneste New Hampshire kid
Governor State coordinator
[Applause]
so it's official
congratulations
so as a teacher
I'm always going to be wanting to teach
you a little something so I'll try to
make it quick
and clear
and fun
so as you learned in fourth grade and
you reviewed this past fall our state
we have a little visual aid here
each branch serves a different purpose
and the branches check and balance one
another so no one branch holds too much
power
this structure is put forth in our New
which was signed and adopted June 2nd
1784 that was
239 years ago and we still use it every
day
the state constitution holds the
foundational rules and laws that we live
by a kind of rules of the game for those
of us who live here in the granite state
the oath of office that you will hear
chief justice
McDonald read aloud for Hayden
is adapted from this New Hampshire
Constitution
today we will experience firsthand the
three branches of government in our
beautiful state
we are honored to hear
from house Speaker Sherman Packard who
represents the legislative branch
chief justice Gordon McDonald who will
who leads the judicial branch
and we are fortunate today to have two
representatives from the executive
branch
executive counselor Janet Stevens and
Governor Christopher sununu
the house Speaker who was going to speak
New Hampshire is a pretty unique state
we have the largest
legislative body of any state in the
country
in the New Hampshire house
we have 400 members
the next largest legislative body in the
country is Pennsylvania with 203.
we are truly the only legislative body
in this country that is still a citizen
legislature that is left
do any of you know how much we get paid
we get a whole hundred dollars a year
yeah
I see a lot of surprise faces out there
that is our salary one hundred dollars
but I must admit as Speaker I get an
this makes us truly a citizen
legislature that salary was put in
existence back in I think was 1888 and
we still get the same amount of money
we do not get a per diem as many other
states do or uh any kind of a uh you
know a daily uh sum of money
so we truly do get one hundred dollars a
year
you're also sitting in the chamber
that was first started being used back
in 18
.
we just had our 200th anniversary a few
I know everyone that is a state
representative
in this state
is extremely proud of the fact that we
Are Who We Are
in how much time each representative
puts in to try and make New Hampshire a
better place
and so you'll also notice
the state senators which are 24 which is
one of the lowest uh bodies of state
senators they also get 100 bucks a year
they don't get anything more than we do
so we do have a unique state it works
and I believe we live in the best state
in the Union by far
and I know all of us will continue to
make sure that we continue to be the
best state in the Union and I know we
will succeed in that
uh now I'd like to introduce um
councilor Janice Stevens and she can
give you a brief explanation of the
council
[Applause]
good morning
congratulations kid Governor Simmons and
executive counselors parent cook Swanson
Belanger segoya and Strahan Howe on your
election success and for stepping up to
serve the 1.3 million people who live in
New Hampshire your hard work
your perseverance your passion for
public service and your desire to make
New Hampshire a better State LED you to
this point today
so well done
also supporting you and getting elected
your teachers your families the New
Hampshire Institute of politics and
education and Ms Drew can all of the
kids stand up and give a big round of
applause for all of those folks that
foreign
[Applause]
executive counselor Janet Stevens I
represent District 3 along with
counselor Swanson and I need to speak
with you after the meeting regarding a
1.6 million dollar infrastructure
project in Salem okay so stick around
um
and I am honored
to represent
266 000 residents living in 32 towns and
cities from the Seacoast to Salem I'm
honored to be speaking to an auditorium
full of Future Leaders of America it's a
great day
New Hampshire's executive Council dates
back to 1690 and was the first of its
kind and is the only remaining form of
government in the United States which
the executive branch
is co-shared by our governor
and five elected executive counselors
New Hampshire's governor and executive
Council has become the most democratic
form of executive government in the
nation
the governor and executive Council
meetings are typically held every other
Wednesdays
and they're open to the public and I
hope that all of you will have a chance
to visit the executive Council chamber
today sit at the table you can sit at my
desk in my office as well
as well as attend a meeting and we are
meeting this Wednesday
as an executive counselor I approve
contracts over ten thousand dollars I
serve as the Watchdog of our state's
Treasury
approve appointments of Judges justices
and Commissioners who had our state
agencies
I oversee 750 million dollars
in transportation infrastructure
projects
which include roads Bridges ports and
airports
Point more than 300 citizens to serve on
our state boards and commissions
um And in regards to infrastructure
governor-elect we have a major project
on 125 in Plaistow it's a Safety project
to make it safer
but I am a fierce advocate for making
certain the residents I represent get
their fair share of funding and services
I'm also fiercely protective of my
constituents and spend every day
involved with constituent case work
either assisting a resident at risk of
losing their home assisting a town when
their school children were forced to use
bottled water due to groundwater
contamination and we solve that problem
um also assisting in emergency
management team on Friday when they
needed additional resources for their
preparation for the executive Council
starts on Friday afternoons preceding a
meeting
a New Hampshire state trooper arrives at
my front door with either one carton two
to three cartons of documents that I
must review prior to the next executive
council meeting five days later last
year I read 2200 contracts for this
Wednesday's meeting there are 145
contracts for review
the governor sets the agenda and runs
the meeting for a governor to be
successful he or she must be able to
count to three because he's going to
need the majority of the council to get
his agenda across
I fully utilize my role on the executive
Council and as an executive Council to
improve and Elevate the lives of my
constituents
I know that all of you are going to do
the same you've all identified critical
issues which are priorities of mine as
well
homelessness the risks associated with
pediatric vaping which counselor segoya
highlighted to food insecurity we know
that 9.5 percent of children in New
Hampshire are struggling and living with
fear that they're not certain where
their next meals are coming from
so with the approval from your parents
and teachers I would love to take you
all for a visit to the New Hampshire
Food Bank where we can meet the leaders
who are responsible for getting food out
to our 400 Partners across the state you
guys are awesome you did a great job and
very proud of you and I'm sure you hear
[Applause]
now we'll have the Chief Justice of this
state supreme court
chief justice McDonald
[Applause]
good morning everyone thank you very
much Mr Speaker Governor councilor
Stevens
it is truly an honor to be before you
today uh the judicial branch is a proud
partner with NH Civics and and The
Institute of politics in advancing
Civics education and and it's truly
thrilling to be up here and to be part
of the such an important program
uh on behalf of all in the judicial
branch I want to congratulate our
governor-elect Hayden Simmons and her
family as well as our new counselors and
their families and to kid Governor uh
Charlotte cotty and counselors we thank
you for your service and and Governor I
want to thank you for your voice
your advocacy and your inspiration over
the last year is truly remarkable
as we heard from Martha and as you all
know we have three branches of
government
the people through their elected
representatives and senators make our
laws the executive through our governor
implements the laws and the judicial
branch through our judges interpret and
apply the law
but on this day when we are inaugurate a
new governor all three branches come
together in this room
and we come together to put on display
the very Foundation of our democracy
which is the rule of law
the ultimate law of our state the
Constitution sets forth the terms of the
governor in the manner of his or her
election
today we follow those laws and if in a
few minutes
the authority of the governor will
transfer from Charlotte Governor cotti
to Hayden Governor Simmons
in our state judges are nominated by the
governor
and after hearing in public input they
are approved by our executive Council
we have two trial courts
a circuit court and a superior court
and our trial courts are located
throughout the state we have about 40
courthouses in New Hampshire and about
65 trial judges
when someone is accused of a crime
either a judge or a jury will decide if
she or he is guilty and a judge will
decide whether they should go to jail or
prison and for how long
when two parties have a dispute they can
appear before a judge and have the
dispute resolved
and when the parties don't agree with
what the trial court has done they can
appeal to the Supreme Court and their
five justices on the Supreme Court and
they will decide whether the judge
followed the law
whatever the case our job as judges is
to listen to everyone and to decide what
is fair and what the law requires
all judges wear black robes like I'm
wearing today
the role symbolizes the role of the
judge
to be completely neutral and to uphold
our rule of law
our gathering today symbolizes and
celebrates how important the rule of law
is to our state and to our country
it is an honor and very exciting to be
part of it
thank you all of you and those streaming
online for being part of it and
and now uh it's my high honor to
introduce our governor his Excellency
Christopher tsunam
[Applause]
thank you thank you thank you
all right
with all this up and down that's how we
in the State House get our all the
exercise
are you guys excited
you should be this is a great day you
should be excited we're gonna uh swear
in a new governor with Hayden that in
itself is very exciting
um you're not in class that's kind of
cool
and and with all these politicians
droning on with speeches Chances Are by
the time you get back to class it'll be
too late to get any homework tonight so
that's the other piece of good news
nothing like the governor telling kids
they don't need homework
um well hey this is absolutely great I
I'm gonna do my best not to go on too
too long
um but first obviously a huge
congratulations to Hayden and a big
thank you to Charlotte uh with with
these delays that we've had because it's
been extended a few weeks uh Charlotte
you may be the longest serving Governor
uh kid Governor we'll see we'll see
actually what happens
um I don't want to repeat too much of
what was said because these folks the
fact that you have the Chief Justice and
the Secretary of State and someone from
the Janet from the executive Council and
the speaker of the house and the
Senators and this really rarely rarely
happens that all these folks would be in
this room so it really does signify I
think how important that those of us
here already within the state house uh
see this this opportunity
um as the speaker we're saying we have a
a citizen government we really do unlike
any other state that's Governor I travel
all across the country I talk to other
Governors and I'm not kidding when I
tell you they go how do you do it they
see our system and they don't understand
how we do it in New Hampshire we're so
unique we're not like any other state
the fact we have 400 Representatives you
can be 18 years old doesn't matter how
much money you have or your name ID or
anything anybody who wants to get up and
serve can serve and you can do that in
as the House of Representatives right
you can go I don't know I met an 18 year
old girl she spent 20 she worked her job
she spent 25 bucks she made a bunch of
posters at Kinkos and she knocked on
about the 2 000 doors a few times over a
few months and introduced herself and
she won that's it that's it she won she
just knocked on doors and talked to as
many people as possible and now she's
here in the House of Representatives
which is just an amazing opportunity
Most states you can't do that and
whether it's serving in the House of
Representatives or in the senate or
running for office or the planning board
or the school board or donating time at
the non-profit or giving something of
yourself that's the true difference in
New Hampshire no matter whether you're
elected or not all 1.4 million of us we
have a responsibility give back somehow
find your thing right find what you
enjoy doing find what your your special
talent is because everyone has one
sometimes we got to dig a little to find
it I had to figure out what mine was
took me like forever to figure it out
but find a way to give back and
sometimes it's just giving a little bit
of your time to your community and we do
that really really well here the
solutions are not just up here in
Concord the solutions are in your
schools or at your town meeting and town
meeting is coming up in most of your
your talents which is pretty wild and
exciting
um with the school boards or the uh the
non-profits that do so much work in your
community so find a way to give back uh
through that process and the fact that
you're here means you guys are already
on track and that what we want to do is
is spread this message as much as
possible so
um from kids to grandparents everybody
uh really kind of has that opportunity
it really is amazing now this is really
not about me I know I'm the governor but
as was mentioned a little bit here
before the real credit uh that I and the
big thank you I have to give is to the
person who is not here unfortunately she
is sick today and she didn't want to
come up she didn't want she wanted to
make sure she didn't get anyone sick
she's doing well but that's my wife
Valerie the first lady she is the one
that really when I we learned about this
program she is the one that kind of took
the program on her shoulders and
championed and worked with Luanne and
Martha and the teams to say not just how
do we do it right it's easy to do it but
how do we make it bigger how do we grow
it how do we get it more exciting how do
we make sure that it isn't just like a
one day a year thing hey we swore the
kid governor in great we'll see you next
year no no no no no no
um there's a lot of work behind this
there is and it's exciting work it's an
exciting opportunity it means some
public speeches it means going to a lot
of public events
um and whether it's with myself or with
the first lady I saw Charlotte all the
time at this and that I would show up at
an event and there she was so the folks
here at New Hampshire Civics have done a
phenomenal job of making sure this isn't
just a fun thing to do one time of the
year it really is an obligation and an
opportunity to go around and share this
this um this the the initials whether
it's around homelessness or just hear
from you guys right you're the peer
group and so you get to talk to this
this kid governor and say this is what
we should be talking about at the state
level and don't forget about this issue
and this is a new thing that we want to
and it could be anything right it could
be on animals it could be on the
homeless issue it could be on you know
our drug and opioid crisis and mental
health issues it could be on so many
different things because there's so much
so much work to be done but Valerie was
the one that really I think understood
this as a former school teacher and as a
mom I really understood the power that
this program was having so in that she
wrote a letter and she said if you don't
read this letter word for word don't
bother coming home
because she will find out about it she's
going to get texts if I don't hit it on
on the butt button so let me this is a
letter from the first lady dear kid
governor of New Hampshire 2023 Hayden
uh my name so it's kind of weird my name
is Valerie sununu sorry and my title is
first lady or some prefers to say some
prefer to say first spouse of the State
of New Hampshire I wasn't elected to
this position but because my husband
Chris is Governor I'm able to shine a
light on some amazing opportunities and
people in the granite state just like
you
I've been an artist supporter of the New
Hampshire kid Governor program since its
Inception and each year the kid governor
and executive Council impresses and
humbles me and this year is no exception
I saw I saw your surprise announcement
on YouTube when you first found out that
you had earned the majority of votes
from fifth graders across the state your
school showered you with the celebration
and support and you immediately asked to
call your mom
it was always it is always been so
inspiring and touching to see a breath
the breadth and depth of support for
such a leader in order to do your job
well you will benefit from the support
of your community and family and with
your leadership and vision along with
the support of your family and your
community you will do amazing work to
help end hunger and poverty in New
Hampshire I'm here to amplify your
message and voice anytime that is
possible get ready for lots of public
speaking Hayden we're all here for you
for your support to give you the support
your calling and that calling to help
others congratulations and have so much
fun as the New Hampshire kid governor
with gratitude and support Valerie
sununu
so at this time I'm going to ask Hayden
to come on up and ask uh the gov so the
governor-elect can take her oath of
office and be joined by Chief Justice
Gordon McDonald to administer Leo
governor
listen carefully to the falling oath of
office and at the conclusion of the oath
we say I do
you solemnly swear or affirm that you
will Faithfully perform the duties at
the office of New Hampshire's kid
Governor to the best of your abilities
and that you will support and defend the
Constitutions of the United States in
the state of New Hampshire so help you
God
what an honor it is to stand here with
all of you I'd like to start off by
thanking Governor sununu along with
first lady sununa I'd also like to thank
everyone that ran for New Hampshire good
governor and the teachers and principals
that helped out with this program I
would especially like to thank my
parents and family my teachers Mrs
co-worker Mrs Hazelton and political
principals Mrs lafrenier and Mrs Lee
and also I'd also like to thank New
Hampshire kid Governor coordinator Luan
genest executive director of New
Hampshire Civics Martha Madsen the team
from New Hampshire Institute of politics
at St Anselm College my wonderful
executive Council Andrew Ava Emily
Jordan Kaylee and Sierra and all of you
that came here today
I'm Hannah Simmons I am a fifth grader
at Paulding elementary school and I am
your 2023 New Hampshire good governor
my entire
my entire life my mom has told me about
when she was little and how she never
knew when her next meal might be you
taught me to be grateful for what I have
and not to complain about what I don't
have
I realized this was a big Community
issue during the pandemic I heard about
people who couldn't afford food water
rent clothes or other important
Necessities once the opportunity
opportunity to run for New Hampshire get
Governor presented itself I started to
research poverty and hunger in our state
once I looked at the charts I knew I
needed to run for New Hampshire Governor
I needed to make positive change in our
state
I read on the feeding America website
that one out of 14 people suffer from
hunger every day and one out of 11 of
them are children that's just in the
state of New Hampshire I also read that
7.6 of New Hampshire's population suffer
from poverty every day
there are many wonderful programs out
there for example Governor sununa's SNAP
program which provides nutrition
benefits for low-income individuals and
families but these programs are still
not enough
sometimes when you get hungry or cold
you might say I'm starving or I'm
freezing imagine not having enough food
in your fridge to be able to go and get
a snack or even a meal whenever you
needed to imagine not having enough heat
in your home to be able to go inside and
get warm that's what it really feels
like to be starving and that's what it
really feels like to be freezing
you might be wondering how you can help
you can help by donating encouraging
others to donate educating yourself and
others on the issue and helping out at
local organizations and programs I look
forward to working with my executive
Council to do these things and more
thank you all again for coming and
supporting me I look forward to
representing all of the kids in our
state as your New Hampshire good
governor I believe that if we work
together we can put an end to poverty
and hunger in their in the state of New
Hampshire
[Applause]
congratulations Aiden at this time our
new
New Hampshire kid Governor will
administer the oath to the kid executive
Council
please raise your right hand
do you solemnly swear or affirm that you
will Faithfully perform the duties of
the office of New Hampshire's kid
executive counselor to the best of your
congratulations
right
[Applause]
we have some certificates for our new
executive counselors
Sierra Belanger
of Namaste Montessori School
congratulations
Haley cook of Beaver Meadows School in
Emily parent of Edward Fenn Elementary
Ava strand Howe of Andover middle school
Jordan seguya Bicentennial Elementary
and Andrew Swanson of North Salem
Elementary in Salem
[Applause]
at this time you may sit down thank you
very much
um so at this time I believe speaker
Packard has
uh first of all Governor have you hired
um uh Senator Abbas I know you have
[Music]
thank you Mr Speaker
I'm Senator Daryl Abbas I do represent
District 22 communities of Pelham Salem
my hometown
Atkinson and plastow so I this is
distinct honor to do this to present
these resolutions and bragging rights of
my colleagues I believe we have the kid
governor and kid executive Council from
District 22. so thank you very much for
both of you for making my district look
awesome
I I do have a resolution for Hayden
Simmons
be it known that the New Hampshire
Senate extends its congratulations to
Hayden Simmons from Pollard Elementary
School in recognition of being elected
the next
New Hampshire kid governor for 2023 and
to be further known that the entire New
Hampshire Senate extends its best wishes
for your continued success
[Applause]
history
and it really it just speaking maybe the
obvious how awesome it is to see so many
young Future Leaders in the state here
in reps Hall it really is amazing and
just so you know to be a state
representative all you have to do is be
18 before your term begins not by the
election time so the first Wednesday in
December if you're 18 before then you
and this is uh on behalf of Mr Swanson
be it known that the New Hampshire State
Senate extends its congratulations to
Andrew Swanson from North Salem
Elementary School in recognition of
being elected as New Hampshire's kid
executive Council for 2023 and it be
further known that the entire New
Hampshire Senate extends its best wishes
for your continued success thank you
thank you
[Applause]
so I do have a lot of paperwork up here
I was trying to do the handshake and not
so some of my colleagues I couldn't be
here today I know our Senator Innis had
a conflict in schedule but I'd like to
present this on his behalf to uh Ava
I do have a resolution if you can come
if you're out of order the speaker will
say something but I think you're okay
let it be known that the New Hampshire
Senate extends its congratulations to
Ava Strahan Howe of Andover Middle
School in recognition of being elected
New Hampshire's 2023 kid executive
counselor gonna be further known that
the New Hampshire Senate extends his
best wishes to the continued success
and as I said before congratulations and
keep up the good work and thank you very
much
[Applause]
I do have another resolution this is for
Sierra
I kind of change it as I go
so let it be known
that the New Hampshire Senate extends
it's congratulations to Sierra Belanger
got it right
uh not Namaste Montessori School in
recognition of being elected at New
Hampshire's 2020-23 kid executive
counselor and be further known that the
New Hampshire Senate extends its best
wishes for continued success this is on
behalf of Senator Senator Murphy can be
here today but congratulations and
please keep up the good work and thank
[Applause]
this is this is for Emily parent you can
and let it be known
that the New Hampshire Senate extends
its congratulations to Emily parent
from Edward Fenn School in Gorham in
recognition of being elected as New
Hampshire kid executive Council for 2023
and be further known that the entire New
Hampshire State Senate extends its best
wishes for your continued success thank
you again keep up the good work and I'm
proud of all all the kids and all the
kids here today and thank you thank you
again
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
thank you speaker
Senator Cindy Rosenwald from Nashua
district 13 which is two-thirds of
Nashua and I have a resolution for
be it known that the New Hampshire
Senate extends its congratulations to
Jordan seguya in recognition of being
elected New Hampshire kid executive
counselor 2023 and be it further known
that the New Hampshire Senate extends
its best wishes for continued success
congratulations
last but very not least my name is Becky
Whitley I am a state senator that
represents Concord Hopkinton and Beau
and I have to say as a mom I am so proud
of all of you for all the work that you
did to get here and also to all the
students here this is the most beautiful
site in the house chamber so thank you
so much for all being here so I am very
grateful to present a resolution to
Kaylee cook if you'd like to come up and
the New Hampshire Senate a resolution be
it known that the New Hampshire Senate
extends its congratulations to Kaylee
cook from Beaver Meadow School in
Concord in recognition of being elected
as a New Hampshire kid executive
executive counselor for 2023 and be it
further known that the entire New
Hampshire Senate extends its best wishes
for your continued success
congratulations
[Applause]
Hayden could you uh
[Music]
I'd like to give you a resolution from
the New Hampshire House of
Representatives
Vietnam at the New Hampshire House of
Representatives extended congratulations
to kid Governor Hayden Simmons in
recognition and appreciation for her
dedication to end in poverty and hunger
[Applause]
the first thing I want to say is I
cannot believe how well-behaved you guys
are to have all of you sit here for this
amount of time it's quite amazing
congratulations to your teachers
I have the pleasure of reading two
letters sent to us for Hayden and her
executive counselors from U.S senators
Jin chihin and Maggie Hassan the first
two they are the first two female
elected governors of New Hampshire and
the first female elected U.S senators
dear friends
I regret that I cannot be with you today
but I join you in celebrating the
inauguration of New Hampshire's newest
kid Governor Hayden Simmons
with our vibrant Civic Society robust
citizen legislature in numerous local
boards and advisor advisory panels New
Hampshire does democracy better than any
place else
we have long played a critical role in
American democracy in the involvement of
Hayden and her executive Council in the
kid Governor program reflects our strong
tradition of Civic engagement
to Hayden
and the members of the executive Council
Sierra Emily Jordan Kaylee Ava and
Andrew congratulations on the beginning
of your terms I encourage you to
continue to continue to learn about the
world we live in and to stand up for
your values you have important years
ahead and I know that you will continue
to stay engaged in our democracy and
keep working to make a difference in our
communities
Hayden I am particularly impressed by
your goal of ending poverty and hunger
in New Hampshire and I am grateful for
your commitment to your fellow Granite
Staters
thank you to everyone here today for
your support of our children in their
education and Civic engagement with
[Applause]
dear Governor Simmons congratulations on
your recent election as New Hampshire's
2023 kid governor New Hampshire's kid
Governor program is a great way to learn
about Civic involvement public service
and our system of state government as a
former New Hampshire Governor myself I
can say from personal experience that
public service in Concord provides many
opportunities to build meaningful
relationships discover the value of
becoming involved in the Greater
Community and learn essential leadership
skills like listening and speaking with
Clarity on behalf of others
I hope this Spirit of Civic involvement
will stay with you throughout your Youth
and I hope you enter adulthood with the
knowledge that you too can make a
difference in the lives of your peers
it is so important for young people like
you to play an active role in shaping
the future you will inherit I urge you
to continue to look for ways to get
involved in the issues for which you are
deeply
which you care deeply find your passions
and follow them if you approach these
issues with energy and positivity you'll
find there is no limit to what you can
achieve congratulations once again and
best wishes to you in your bright future
I'd like to say that Senator Jean
Shaheen from Senator Gene Shaheen I'd
like to say that she wrote you each a
letter individually
and sent them to you and sent them to
you in this beautiful United States
Senate folder so I'll be giving that to
thank you all for being here today
um
this time the fifth graders from The
Pollard school will be singing
[Music]
us
free
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
this session is adjourned
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]